[Music]
Miley Cyrus and Cody Simpson are still
going strong at least if tick-tock is
any indication and yeah Miley is in her
bra and we even got coordinated dance
moves amazing
now Miley and Cody clearly left
tick-tock we also got this video Cody
posted his tick-tock with Miley to his
insta story and wrote quote just
discovered tick tock
follow me for premium content we're
talking premium to be fair that was all
premium content Miley and Cody have been
spending a lot of time together lately
remember this video we got them
channeling the Joker and when Miley was
in the hospital Cody not only visited
her you can't take this guy anywhere
nope you can't take this guy anyway rip
some Elvis everywhere I go but he wrote
a song for her
[Music]
but earlier this month after the pair
first sparked romance rumors a source
told et that they had no plans to start
dating each other exclusively and they
both just wanted to have fun and were
being open and honest with each other
about that we also know the pair goes
way back she's definitely like a very
like at heart a very very sweet normal
like girlfriend from Nashville like and
we were spending hang out at her ranch
in Nashville and she's just like I'm
just like a lot of people say these
things like that you know she's just
like the coolest Jake alright guys
that's it for today for all the latest
on Miley and Cody keep it locked to all
things
ét until next time i'm katie Krauss and
bye for now
[Music]